[Music]
legend has it there is a tree in the
Amazon that possesses unparalleled
healing powers and the Arrowhead is the
key to unlocking it stop man hello I
just wanted you to know this has been
mislabeled
he's shipping outlets
of all the jungle cruisers you can take
in the Amazon
this one is undoubtedly the cheapest but
also the most thrilling heads up come a
Duke
look out
Marauders
natives ladies and gentlemen the moment
you've all been waiting for
the backside of water stays wonder of
the world
we're headed upriver lagrimas de cristo
mister Huron travel calm not a good time
looking for passage upriver please go
away
I have a lot of money ever you believe
in legends you should believe in curses
- you're gonna beg minutes are back well
I look forward to disappointing you
10,000 to bring you there alive
dead is 15,000 why should I pay more
dead
dead-eyed have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady here we go
[Music]
oh god sorry Frank sorry strong form
hi Jenna swim you put the river cruising
you can't swim
the price just went out
okay Olaf you're up unicorn Oh Oh laughs
you get to rearrange doesn't matter this
is gonna be a cinch
Oh distracted worried
[Music]
how's Elsa seemed weird to you
she seems like Elsa there's this voice
voice what does that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers
across the enchanted lands into the
unknown we do this together okay
the spirits will challenge your every
step of the way
[Music]
that's normal
who are you hi I'm Olaf oh sorry yeah I
just find clothes restricting
Oh
should I know what that means
giant huge
screen
magic disappearing without you she may
lose herself to it I believe in you more
than anyone or anything
if anyone can save arendelle it's you
what are you guys cope with the ever
increasing complexity of thought that
comes with maturity no no don't you that
you don't know what I stepped it you
know what a Harlequin is the Harlequins
role is to serve it's nothing without a
master no one gives two shits who we are
beyond that
the Joker and I broke up what did a
fresh start
but it turns out I wasn't the only
daemon got them looking for emancipation
new screen she tossed me
[Applause]
who you got
[Music]
[Applause]
you need
all of us
we should order because
[Applause]
[Music]
who's having a good time
you should never call a woman check I'll
accept broth lady coming by on occasion
[ __ ] anyway it's been ten years since
the zombie apocalypse functional family
very do you know what I would like I
don't have a [ __ ] with me like that
survived by using their WIC sees nothing
personal how could that not be personal
that's like my whole thing yeah you're
right it was personal
on October 18 what made you do it and
don't say the script can this be just
between us drugs cost money didn't see
that coming right you'll be the first to
die but I like your enthusiasm you might
die yeah thank you for your sacrifice
from the directive that
me too right oh yes
and my dues of Deadpool Casablanca okay
well I think I would have made a damn
fine president I think those cigars were
left over from the Clinton
administration Academy Award nominee
what do you Harrelson let's kick some
dick Award nominee Jesse Eisenberg right
now that sings very 2009 those two yes
can you know either me simply hey yo
let's go we're running late it has
always been like this idea
see Juana's cincuenta daniela Ramos
[Music]
that is not your progress come with me
or you're dead in the next 30 seconds
you know machina can make it even better
who puts it busted by us
you Danny you're my mission
[Music]
what is that my name is Sarah Connor I
hunt terminators enough of a resume for
you
how do we stop this thing
I'm going to help you change the future
I'm done running I'm gonna stand and
fight
you can't die
if you don't make it
everybody dies why not just let me have
it
because we're not machines metal mother
[Music]
in times of all the world was full of
wonder and magic but times change warner
mama hey birthday boy by the laws of
your I must dub the a man today kneel
before me that's okay
I have a gift from your dad he said to
give you this when you were both over
sixteen no it's a wizard step dad was a
wizard well your dad was an accountant
this spell brings him back for one all
day dad will be back watch I click back
to life that's not possible it is with
this I'm gonna meet dad
ah hisses legs I definitely remember
that having a top part Oh what did I do
hi we only have 24 hours to bring the
rest of him back oh hey Dad you look
just like I remember
[Music]
problem
you see you come to the right pattern
[Music]
we might be out of gas but it says we
have a full tank that doesn't work
growth spell we grow the can and then
the gas inside will grow with it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is huge and you're the corner over there
you really ruining my story right now
you know that I got an issue his
movement man
[Music]
we have 15 minutes it's time hit it
[Music]
hello boys
or if I told you I know what happens
when you die you become a ghost die more
criminal records
no more office parties are stupid
weddings
best part of being dead is the freedom
not policies or politics no one touch is
mine we answer to no one
you could take out some truly evil
people
[Music]
okay
[Music]
these people were declared a day none of
us will be remembered it's about to
happen will dude thinks honey rays the
better ones right the hell are you
for no one
if they exist they can be made not
yeah
sorry for yelling welcome to the world's
biggest magnet
[Music]
I know this road work I mean I wasn't
sure I had a suspicion but I yeah this
is awesome [ __ ] dangerous
I wants to play a game with me ray I
don't want to play a game
oh please no I said play a game with me
right right badly I want you to imagine
a character your boss Mickey
piss you're too smart to be blackmailing
us Fletcher hey sweet Mary Jane is my
vice your boys on the other hand is and
always has been the destroyer of worlds
you're out of touch and I would like you
to consider an offer I am not for sale
the plot begins to thicken now I can't
be specific about the heroes and zero
but how a protagonist is a hungry animal
there is a lot of money hanging in the
balance our antagonist explodes on a
seed black a millennial firewire and has
indirectly started a war I think you
need to see this boss
[Music]
they find it make inquiries his name is
[ __ ] we spelled with a pH I was like
[ __ ] late sorry for how kind of a hoc
bills
if you smell smoke it's because there's
a fire do you get a stamp that out
quickly these people are gonna clean
house and you are part of that house in
the jungle only way a lion survives not
by acting like okay
[Music]
it's really warming up now isn't it was
I one role in this game between the
lines hungry
[Music]
/ associates or not so you killed
someone no it was the gravity that
killed him those phones hello
you're in grave danger get out of there
now open safe house 6
welcome to the Townsend agency I run a
covert group of exceptional women some
guys are like lady spies we work outside
the rules in secret together
you may not know we exist but we are
always watching you are in the presence
of angels so you want to train to be an
angel hell yeah give me the wings
[Music]
sit down keep your hands where I can see
them really not supposed to be touching
things in here unless you're supposed to
be touching things again you're adorable
Jane is that you flirting with a
handsome
[Music]
the best part is them picking down
international criminals
with you guys
in the day drinking that's what I like
the most
[Music]
so I can just take whatever I want Baro
is that an actual rule
hey time to go to work
[Music]
hey I'm Haley
hello down the road Amelia you say
you're what like allergic to the world
right I guess you could say that they
looked everywhere for a doctor to help
you usually get better promise punished
hello Eli I'm dr. horn hello
I hope you don't think of this as a
medical facility to me it's a home and
for now it's your home but so everything
we hoped for is right here shall we
begin
what do you think is making you sick
lots of things the air water dust Eli's
gonna get worse before he gets better
throw something in my room
bad dreams are a side effect it's
perfectly normal I don't need to freak
you out but this place gives me the
creeps
I think she's making me sicker America
no it's not the medication why do I feel
worse because it's working something bad
is happening
[Music]
you're doing it better promise
[Music]
let's get a new tape going all right
Richard here's what we're gonna do we
need a voice exemplar I want you to say
into this phone there's a bomb in
Centennial Park you have 30 minutes
Richard your national hero now thank you
sir
but I'll just do my job you always look
at the guy who found the bomb just like
you always look at it I've found the
body jewel fits the profile of the lone
bomber a frustrated white man who is a
police wannabe who seeks to become a
hero
we're running it you're a suspect you
don't talk I talk say Auto tone this
might be the only way to clear your name
I want you to say there's a bomb in
Centennial Park you have 30 minutes does
that kind of be their best friend I was
raised to respect authority Authority
looking to eat you alive
there's a bomb in Centennial Park you
have 30 minutes I'm sorry what his
accusers are two of the most powerful
forces in the world the United States
government and the media
I do want to help y'all law enforcement
to
there is a bomb in Centennial Park you
have 30 minutes Richard Jewell is an
innocent man he's a hero
there's a bomb in Centennial Park you
have 30 minutes
one more time still alone I report the
fact you brewing this man's life there
is a bomb in Centennial Park you have 30
minutes to a couple of my son
[Music]
there is a bomb in Centennial Park you
have 30 minutes
I don't get how to protect you
religion quite as he leaves out they
want to fire you
you ready start fighting back whoa Oh
mommy where's sweetie
[Music]
I'm so sorry for partying you're in luck
darling
I've worked on many a bite out here let
me help her
this is crazy
now that this makes sense I think we
almost lost what was done for your
daughter doesn't come cheap your little
girl was spared and now you owe a life
in return for her soul
it's out you only have it to censor
you best get a move
salt can be any one of your cheese but
it must be healed you out in something I
can see in your eyes I love you so so
much sweetie
[Music]
[Music]